hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over what
i think is the greatest chess opening
or at least the most fun and to me chess
is all about having fun and that is the
triple museo gambit i'm all about
giving up material in exchange for a
very very strong attack and the triple
museo gambit derives from the king's
gambit which
i've always been a huge fan of the
king's gambit
just a warning to everyone out there if
you're looking for a very sound
opening that you're going to be taking
to tournaments with two-hour time
controls
you're in the wrong place for everyone
else that likes to have fun
this is going to be the opening for you
starts out with the king's gambit e4
e5 f4 after the pawn takes knight to f3
all about rapid development in this
opening
g5 here don't care too much about that
bishop to c4
pawn g4 still don't care castle on the
king side
take the knight completely fine with us
queen to f3 getting involved into the
game
queen to f6 pretty common way for black
to respond
in the museo gambit uh we're not done
giving out material here
e5 really trying to get the queen away
from this
f7 square so after the queen takes here
bishop takes on f7 king takes on f7 you
can start to see the king
is open for attacks here and then we're
gonna play
d4 giving up more material
because just giving up sums not enough
we already gave up a bishop and a knight
now it's time to give up both of our
central pawns
and after the queen takes here on d4
then we have
bishop to e3
and you can immediately see the threat
that black is under
the rook and the queen are on this
f-file
lined up with this king right here and
so the queen can't just take here
because the queen can recapture the pawn
is pinned
so that's not going to work here the
queen's under attack the queen is going
to be forced to move
and you can see the king here on f7
is just wide open a lot of attacking
lines that white has we're going to be
going over those today some key concepts
to think about
in the opening it's always good to know
the moves as far as if your opponent
goes you don't want to spend too much
time
thinking but it's also good to
understand the concepts
in this opening you really want to be
playing so that they don't get
any of their material involved into the
game you can see the rooks
on a8 and h8 really shouldn't be having
any time to develop because that means
they're usually getting their bishop and
they're not involved into the game
if you find yourself allowing your
opponent to do that you're probably
missing something in the attack
white's going to be playing knight to c3
at some point connecting the rooks very
quickly
and really always be looking to attack
the opponent's king
so with that said let's go and jump into
it one of the first things to keep in
mind
is the threats that you have and
no better way to look at that than if
black really just avoids this
threat here on f4 and says well i'm just
going to continue to gobble up material
maybe if i
get capture enough material
that there's no way that white can win
but this is going to be a losing
proposition because
black really needs that queen evolved
into the game queen to f4
it's gonna be very difficult for black
to hold on to this there's no real way
for the king to move
uh without it being a checkmate so that
the obvious ones are king to e8
well that's just going to be checkmate
right there uh king 2
e7 you can chase the king around the
board a little bit
but this is going to be a forced mate
here rook over here to d1
and this is part of the reason that we
gave up our central pawns
is so the rooks can attack freely in the
center of
the board they could stop it with their
queen but it's really just taking up a
few moves here
at the end of the day this is going to
be a checkmate now if we come back a few
moves
maybe they don't come to king 2 e7
maybe they were to play king 2 e6
same thing as before queen up here to f7
now maybe if they don't want to just
give up their queen
it's still just going to be a quicker
checkmate king 2
e5 and you can see a very quick
checkmate right there so
probably not going to be moving the king
my guess is in this position they're
either going to be
playing knight to f6 or they're going to
be playing
queen 2 f6 back here uh just says hey i
captured a pawn here
now i can bring my queen back and things
gonna be safe knight to f6 is not going
to work out
because of bishop to d4
and there's no way for black to hold on
to the queen
right here because queen takes on a1
okay well now just queen to f6 and this
is going to end up being checkmate rook
to e1
check and you can see a checkmate
happens very quickly right here um
if they try anything else you know queen
takes on d4
okay well now we're just going to take
that material and we're attacking this
knight here on
f6 uh then we can get our knight
involved into the game get our other
rook involved into the game a lot of
attacking lines here
if they do anything else maybe bishop to
e7 or bishop
to g7 then we can just go ahead and take
their
queen right here on b2 we still have
the pin the knight's not going anywhere
as well so
if they play knight to f6 they are going
to lose their queen in the game now if
they bring their queen back here to
f6 it's not gonna work out that well
for them either because of queen two c4
always important to make sure you
understand when you are playing a game
that you
don't want to exchange down material
especially your powerful pieces this is
a key concept in gambits
so something like queen takes on f6 and
then they just take with their knight
right here
this is extremely bad you start to look
at the material and they're up a lot of
material
absolutely and now you don't have any
major pieces attacking your opponent so
you definitely do not want to be taking
you always want to be looking for the
next attack and the next attack is queen
to
c4 what's nice is because the king is so
wide open there's usually
some very easy checks and forced mates
that you can find on your opponent so
queen to c4
maybe now they play king 2 g7
now we're going to just take their queen
right here maybe knight to f6
knight to c3 we can at some point play
bishop to d4
pinning down the knight we can get the
rook over here to f1
a lot of attacking lines that we have if
instead they play
d5 and here
you want to be taking up here on c7 and
delivering a
check and the reason for that is we'll
go through this line and show you just
how
much better it is for you maybe in this
case they take
with or they play bishop to e7 they
can't move their queen they would like
to play queen e7 but that queen is still
pinned down by this rook here white
queen can take here on
c8 with still the threat of queen takes
here on b7 and taking the rook right
here
now if they want to take material that's
completely fine right here
king takes on f1 but white's still gonna
have a
extremely good game white's up a ton
in this just because the kings in the
open the rook here on a8
and h8 are not doing anything why can it
play at some point
c3 if they want to block off the thread
on a1 they could play knight to c3
here they still have the queen in the
center of the board attacking
definitely going to be good for white
now if we come back instead of taking
here on c7 if white takes on d5
well now king to g6 and after the rook
takes the knight takes here
attacking the queen and white's out of
good attacks
and it's going to be much more difficult
to win in this position so just make
sure that you know exactly
how to capture with your queen and
continue the attack
now you may not always get so lucky they
may not play queen six on b2
and so we always need to be prepared for
what happens if they play
more correctly in the triple museo
gambit one of the ways they could play
is
queen to f6 protecting uh their king
right here saying yeah if you want to
if you want to go ahead and take with
your queen that's fine if you want to
take with your bishop that's fine i'm up
enough in material that i think i can
hold on to this position
key move here is for white to play
knight to c3 and there's a few things
that this does
one is it still says
yeah you can go and take my bishop here
on e3 now
there's no pin to the pawn so i can go
and just take
that bishop here on e3 the next thing it
does is it controls the center of the
board
it also allows for the knight to come to
d5
attacking the queen here on f6 which is
a huge threat that's going to come into
a lot of variations we look at
and it also connects the rooks you
always in the development want to
connect the rooks
and you want to bring them towards the
center of the board and if your king's
opponent's king is exposed in the center
of the board that's even
better so knight to c3 does a lot of
things
for white's game plan
now because it's not so obvious to see
the threats
many times they may feel like hey you've
just continued to give up materials so
maybe you're just giving up this bishop
here on e3
that's definitely a trap here so if they
take here then you have to move
queen to h5 remember you have both the
queen and
the rook here on the f file and so now
you have
a discovered check and a discovered
attack on the queen
on f6 so they have to respond to this so
they could play
king 2 g7 queen is exposed so rook takes
here
on f6 probably going to take with their
knight right here
bad news bears if they decide to take
with their king and expose that you can
get your knight involved into the game
you can also bring your rook over here
as well
but now king 2 g5 check and after
king 2 f7 no other moves
then rook to f1 and you can start to see
all the threats if they get their bishop
to either e7 or g7 then white's going to
be playing
knight 2 d5 if we come back maybe they
don't take
with their pawn maybe they recognize
that this could be a
trap and so what if they played knight
to c6
in this case a common theme is to get
the knight
involved to the d5 square
puts a lot of pressure on the queen here
on f7
also attacks this c7 square as well and
does take away some of the critical
squares that the king potentially could
go to at some point like
e7 so in this case uh they always have
the threats
i always like to point out that if they
do things like queen
takes on b2 you're still going to be
playing
queen 2 h5 check and you still have all
the threats that you have before
this is going to go very poorly for
black white should definitely have
an easy game maybe in this case they
play queen to
g5
i can now take with the bishop here on
f4
and you can see that after the bishop
moves there is going to be a discovered
check here on the king on f7
a lot of threats that black has to deal
with if we see
maybe queen to f5 just trying to stop
some of those threats then queen to b3
and this has a whole another set of
threats that black has to deal with this
does protect the knight here on
d5 but after the bishop moves
the rook is now pinning down the queen
if the knight moves that's a discovered
check here on
the king on f7 so there's so many
threats that black has to deal with
it's very difficult to continue to make
the best moves the entire game for black
if we come back instead of queen to g5
if they play
queen to f5 well in this case i would
play
queen to d1
this still says hey you can't take my
bishop right here because i'm just going
to take your queen it's going to be
check
this does protect the knight here on
d5 from the queen and still has
all the threats that you wanted to
before you could play
rook takes here on f4 pinning down the
queen
and then winning the queen in that
position
so very very difficult for black to
respond in this position as well
if we come back instead of knight to c6
maybe they play bishop to h6 just trying
to add another defender to this pawn
on f4 now white's just going to play
knight to d5 as we talked about before
and this is threatening the queen so
they still can't take that bishop there
on e3
as they would like to
and now you could see black play queen
to e5
just trying to get the queen out of the
pin but still protecting the pawn here
on
f4 and white can just start to exchange
bishop takes
on f4 attacking the queen maybe there's
an exchange right here
knight takes on f4 but you can still see
all the threats while
black does have more material
this opening is all about how much you
have material involved
in the fight and right now black has one
piece and that is the king right here on
e5
just trying to protect the king white
has
the knight very centralized the queen
and the rook on the f-file
can easily swing the rook over here for
added
attacking lines and from black
standpoint
it's very difficult to get either other
rooks involved into the game
the bishop here on c8 stuck for a while
unless they want to
waste some moves just moving some of the
pawns but that doesn't really help too
much
the knights can get involved into the
game but not to any of the squares that
they'd really like to it's very
difficult for black to hold on to this
position
and that's going to be saying bishop 2
h6 but also if the bishop just comes
here to
d6 white's going to be doing the same
thing knight
2 d5 maybe you have
queen to f5 in this position
bishop's still going to take bishop
takes but now we have
queen to b3 same threat as we saw before
where this is hey if the bishop moves
then the queen is going to fall here
if the knight moves that's a discovered
check this queen is protecting
the knight here as well so lots of
different threats that white has
in this game now they could also play
knight to e7 recognizing that white
likes to play knight to d5
and white's still going to play knight
to d5
because if the knight takes here on
d5 then the queen can take on d5 and
after the queen comes to
e8 then just the rook takes here on
f4
so if we come back to the original
position what if the queen comes to
e5 they may look at this and say i don't
want to have my queen on the f file that
looks dangerous but i do want to protect
this pawn here on
f4 so maybe they play this but you can
probably see that bishop two
f4 taking here
is going to be very difficult for black
to hold on to and they could have in
between moves so bishop 2 c5 and then
king 2h1
sure but then how does black really
continue from here
maybe queen to e6 the queen's under
attacks really have to move that
but as soon as the queen moves off this
fifth rank here
queen up to h5 just continues the
the threat here attacking the king right
here
uh and they could see that uh you know
if the
the king comes to
[Music]
let's say e7 then queen takes on
c5 check and capturing material here so
maybe
a d6 protecting that but then now queen
takes up here
on c7 so maybe they look at that and say
okay well i can't have my king on this
long dark square diagonal
and i can't keep it on the light square
so maybe they play king 2
g7 well now bishop to e5
and this is this is just deadly for for
white here because after the knight
comes to
f6 then the rook takes the queen takes
here
and then queen to g5 is a nice little
tactic
because if you look at here and you say
the bishop's going to take and then the
king's going to recapture
okay well that's not as good for white
here but after
the tactic of queen 2 g5 check
the queen can't capture it's being
pinned down by the bishop right here
now after the king comes to f7 then
white captures with f6 check
and has protection from the bishop here
on e5
we have one more variation to go over
and it's really
black's best moved although i think it's
very difficult for to find but if you're
enjoying this video so far and you want
to try out the triple museo gambit
and you think it's as fun as i do if you
wouldn't mind
please hitting that like button
definitely helps the channel out also if
you aren't already subscribed please do
that and turn on the notification bell i
am doing a lot more videos i want to
make sure that
you are aware of all these fun
chest openings that i am putting out
here trying to get some really
in-depth analysis on these uh so they
are a little longer videos but that will
just allow you to come back
anytime you're trying to study these to
make sure i understand all the key
concepts
in critical situations you know exactly
where you should be moving
and what you should be thinking so the
last line we are going to look at
is queen 2 g7 now the computer thinks
this
is the best line uh and while
it is difficult to attack against this i
think it's very difficult for black to
find
queen to g7 i personally have never seen
anyone play queen to g7
but thought i would just bring this up
because sometimes people will
run this through their own analyzers and
then comment and say hey what about
queen to g7 so i thought i'd go ahead
and point
out what would happen if they play this
first we're gonna go and take with our
queen here on
f4 check and then if they play
queen to f6 we need to play queen to c4
same thing as we talked about before you
do not want to trade off a material it
is going to do us
no good if we just trade right here and
they take with their knight right here
we just don't have enough material to
continue our attack so if they play
queen to f6 we've got to be playing this
queen to c4
luckily for us the king's exposed we
have a lot of attacking
lines king 2e8 that's great
you can see the queen is under attack as
soon as
we move our queen the rook right here
is exposed and they can't just take our
rook because they are
under check they can't move the queen to
e6 because it's being pinned down to the
king so you can see this is going to be
very good for us
now the best option that black has in
this position
which i think it's just as hard to find
the queen to g7 here
and that is the knight to f6 because
this just looks like a strange
setup for black but if they can find it
if you watch the video i know some of
you watch these videos to see
how do i play correctly if someone does
these crazy openings against you
well this is how you're going to be
playing it the queen 2 g7 and then
knight 2f6 black is up material here
and this allows for the best defense to
hold on
but still pretty difficult you're still
going to have a lot of attacking lines
coming at you with
knight 2 c3 from here
white's going to be looking to either
play knight to d5
knight to e4 attacking the pinned knight
here on f6
looking to swing the rook over towards
the center of the board
continue the attacking lines because the
queen took here on
f4 does not have the same threats
before is coming here to h5 but does
still have the threats at some point of
coming over here to
c4 so those are some of the things that
you will be thinking about how you can
continue to attack and while
this is the best setup for black by no
means is white out of this game there's
still a lot of threats that white has
and if black doesn't play carefully
you've already seen from all the
attacking lines that white has
it is lights out and definitely going to
end in a very quick
checkmate so um everything we've shown
so far
is under 15 move so if you see yourself
playing this it starts getting to that
20 30 move
it's probably not going well for white
this is going to end in a very quick win
for white a resignation a checkmate
or if they can defend long enough get
their pieces developed
they're probably going to end up winning
but you can see in all the variations
we've gone over
they didn't really develop any of these
back pieces sometimes they can get their
dark square bishop involved into the
game but the rooks never got involved
into the game
the light square bishop didn't do
anything at all and so that's why we
were willing to give up that material
early on
because we have a rapid development that
we can get all of our material
very easily involved into the game and
attacking the exposed
king so thank you guys so much for
watching
what i think is the best chest opening
or at least the most fun as i said and
that is the triple museo gambit you got
to be playing the king
gamut and that's a fantastic opening you
should be playing anyway but thank you
guys so much for watching and if you
haven't hit the like button please do
that and i'll see you
in the next video